who do you think's worst shot free or
your character
and I think Joffrey because he doesn't
do his own dirty work
they're both sick sadistic bastards
aren't they I think we've seen more of
Joffrey like more of ways capable of so
I would probably have to say Joffrey
because we've seen seen his reign of
evil I would have to say Joffrey I think
it's harder to put yourself in Joffrey's
shoes as a character to relate to on
planes or sadistic imagination
I think Joffrey might just like and so
on Joffrey's unpleasant but he sort of
detached if you like from what he does
Ramsay's definitely I think he's more
interested than nothi Joffrey is
interested but yeah around he takes it
to a new level
Joffrey's a bit more you're still insane
but he's a bit more relaxed it takes a
step back kind of thing like Ramsay is a
bit more the problem with Ramsay and one
or two other carries you get the feeling
that they actually take pleasure in
their cruelty I guess you'd have to say
somebody who is cruel but takes pleasure
in it he's probably worse again you did
win in a fight between those two guys I
would like to see him get his hands on
Joffrey absolutely it would give him
like a half Brown half beyond treatment
first of all you push him out the window
then then you do the horrible sort of
yeah mafia [ __ ] I guess Ramsay would win
he seems to be more of a hands-on kind
of dude I don't know the Joffrey in a
face-to-face actually would happen
things terribly well at all and it would
be a very unpleasant death I think for
Joffrey because he would be treated
pretty appallingly they went probably
just getting going you know I mean yeah
what he did to Alfie in season 3 that I
then received in a box it's just I would
Jeffrey did probably if Jeff would do
that yeah I think I was bad as each
other for different reasons I do it
myself
yeah it's something needs to be done do
it yourself in it